ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень» мене звати John Watrous і я технічний директор з освіти в IBM Quantum
це 13-й урок серії і перший урок четвертого та заключного розділу присвяченого квантовим помилкам
корекція квантових обчислень має потенціал для ефективних рішень обчислювальних задач для яких
ефективні класичні алгоритми невідомі і можливо не існують однак є дуже суттєві виклики які
потрібно буде подолати якщо ми хочемо реалізувати великомасштабні квантові обчислення які ми сподіваємось колись стануть
можливими серцем проблеми є те що квантова інформація надзвичайно крихка ти можеш буквально зіпсувати її просто
подивившись на неї і тому щоб працювати правильно квантові комп'ютери повинні ізолювати квантову інформацію яку вони
зберігають від навколишнього середовища в надзвичайній мірі але водночас сам квантовий комп'ютер повинен забезпечити нам
дуже точний контроль над цією квантовою інформацією і це включає правильну ініціалізацію точні та надійні
унітарні операції і звичайно здатність виконувати вимірювання щоб ми могли фактично отримати результати
обчислень між цими вимогами очевидно є певна напруга і на ранніх етапах квантових обчислень деякі вважали що крихкість
квантової інформації та її сприйнятливість до неточностей та шуму навколишнього середовища в кінцевому підсумку
зробить квантові обчислення неможливими сьогодні мало хто сумнівається що побудова точного та надійного
великомасштабного квантового комп'ютера є монументальним завданням але у нас є ключовий інструмент який допоможе нам у цих зусиллях що призводить більшість
людей обізнаних у цій галузі до оптимізму щодо того що великомасштабні квантові обчислення колись стануть реальністю і цей інструмент — квантова корекція помилок
у наступних чотирьох уроках ми будемо обговорювати квантову корекцію помилок з акцентом на
фундаментальних засадах у цьому уроці ми вперше розглянемо квантову корекцію помилок включаючи один із перших квантових
кодів виправлення помилок — 9-qubit код Шора і ми також обговоримо ще одну фундаментальну концепцію в квантовій
корекції помилок яка відома як дискретизація помилок у подальших уроках розділу ми побачимо більш досконалі і в кінцевому підсумку кращі
конструкції квантових кодів виправлення помилок і ми також обговоримо проблему квантових обчислень на закодованій квантовій інформації з використанням
обчислювальних компонентів які самі по собі недосконалі і схильні до помилок ось короткий огляд
уроку ми почнемо з обговорення класичних кодів повторення які є мабуть найпростішим і найбазовішим типом
класичного коду виправлення помилок класичні коди повторення не є особливо хорошими кодами за класичними
стандартами теорії кодування принаймні самі по собі але це нічого тут ми йдемо за простотою і зокрема
ми розглянемо мабуть найпростіший класичний код виправлення помилок який тільки можна уявити який ми потім використаємо як основу для простого прикладу
квантового коду виправлення помилок цим прикладом є 9-qubit код Шора який ми розглянемо детально
включаючи опис самого коду а також процедури кодування qubit за допомогою цього коду виявлення помилок у закодованих qubit і
виправлення цих помилок і в третій частині уроку ми обговоримо дискретизацію помилок яка дозволяє нам думати про довільні помилки на
qubit які в принципі утворюють континуум можливостей у дискретних термінах по суті зводячи помилки до
так званих бітових перекидань і фазових перекидань перш ніж ми перейдемо до технічних деталей квантової корекції помилок
варто ненадовго зупинитись щоб розглянути потребу в квантовій корекції помилок а також класичній корекції
помилок як я зазначив на початку уроку квантові комп'ютери дуже схильні до помилок через
крихкість квантової інформації зокрема небажані взаємодії з навколишнім середовищем або
іншими словами з рештою світу можуть порушити квантову інформацію ці небажані взаємодії можуть спричинити декогеренцію коли інформація
по суті витікає в навколишнє середовище через що інформація збережена квантовим комп'ютером починає поводитись все більш
класично також критично важливо усвідомити що квантові операції можна виконувати лише з обмеженою
точністю наприклад ми можемо хотіти виконати певний квантовий gate на qubit але через те що фізичні пристрої
ніколи не є ідеальними те що ми фактично реалізуємо може бути лише наближенням до цього gate і це може не бути великою проблемою для
одного gate але якщо наш намір полягає у виконанні тисяч або мільйонів квантових gate ці невеликі неточності
почнуть накопичуватись і коли обчислення завершиться ми можемо отримати стан дуже відмінний від того що ми
очікували тому це є дещо іншим джерелом помилок але це безумовно те чим ми не можемо
нехтувати люди вивчають класичні коди виправлення помилок близько століття і ці коди мають багато застосувань включно з
передачею та зберіганням інформації але оскільки класичні обчислювальні компоненти настільки надійні нам насправді
не потрібна корекція помилок для побудови класичних комп'ютерів тепер може виявитись що корекція помилок насправді не потрібна
і для побудови надійних великомасштабних квантових комп'ютерів наприклад головна ідея топологічних квантових
обчислень полягає в тому що може бути можливим побудувати надійні квантові системи які власне захищені від шуму завдяки
топологічним властивостям систем але ми не знаємо чи це буде можливим і досить широко вважається
що корекція помилок мабуть буде необхідною в тій чи іншій формі для великомасштабних квантових обчислень тепер ми обговоримо класичні
коди повторення які є основою для нашого першого квантового коду виправлення помилок — 9-qubit коду Шора який
ми незабаром побачимо коди повторення є надзвичайно базовими прикладами кодів виправлення помилок
ідея полягає в тому що ми можемо захистити біти від помилок просто повторивши кожен біт певну кількість разів зокрема розглянемо
трибітовий код повторення тут ми кодуємо один біт у три просто повторюючи біт тричі тому
нуль кодується як 000 а одиниця кодується як 111 звичайно якщо нічого не пішло не так ми
можемо легко розрізнити дві можливості але якщо сталася помилка і один із бітів перекинувся скажімо
тобто нуль змінився на одиницю або одиниця змінилась на нуль тоді ми все ще можемо визначити який оригінальний біт
побачивши яке з двох двійкових значень зустрічається двічі рівнозначно ми можемо декодувати обчислюючи значення більшості
або іншими словами двійкове значення яке зустрічається найчастіше і неважко побачити що
якщо у нас є щонайбільше одна помилка бітового перекидання то декодування буде правильним звичайно якщо два біти перекинулись або
всі три біти перекинулись то це не спрацює і ми отримаємо неправильне значення при декодуванні і це загальна властивість
яку має кожен код виправлення помилок ти можеш виправити деякі помилки але ніколи не зможеш виправити кожну помилку і в кінцевому підсумку це
про зменшення шансу помилки а не про гарантію правильності що загалом не є
можливим як приклад ситуації в якій ми можемо зменшити шанс помилки припустимо що наша
мета — передати один біт гіпотетичному одержувачу і для цього ми маємо змогу передавати біти через
так званий двійковий симетричний канал який перекидає кожен переданий біт незалежно з деякою ймовірністю
P тобто з імовірністю 1 мінус P одержувач отримає той біт який ми намагались надіслати але з імовірністю P
біт перекидається і одержувач отримує протилежне значення від того що ми надіслали тому якщо ми не використовуємо код повторення
а натомість просто надсилаємо той біт який маємо на увазі через канал одержувач отримає неправильний біт з
імовірністю P з іншого боку якщо ми спочатку закодуємо біт який хочемо надіслати за допомогою трибітового коду повторення і
потім надішлемо кожен з трьох бітів кодування через канал то кожен з них перекидається з імовірністю P тому
шанс бітового перекидання тепер більший тому що тепер є три біти які потенційно можуть перекинутись а не один
але якщо щонайбільше один біт перекинеться то одержувач зможе правильно декодувати тому ми отримаємо помилку після
декодування тільки якщо два або більше бітів перекинулись під час передачі і нескладно підрахувати що це відбувається з
імовірністю 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P у кубі для значень P менших за 1/12
це призводить до зменшення імовірності того що одержувач отримає неправильний біт певний шанс помилки все одно буде але
код зменшує її ймовірність і якщо ти хочеш зменшити цей шанс ще більше ти можеш зробити це використовуючи
інший код включаючи але не обмежуючись можливістю використання коду повторення де закодований біт повторюється
більше трьох разів для значень P більших за 1/12 до речі код насправді робить
ситуацію гіршою в тому сенсі що збільшує ймовірність того що одержувач отримає неправильний біт тому ми б точно не використовували цей код у такій
ситуації трибітовий код повторення є класичним кодом виправлення помилок але ми також можемо розглянути що відбувається якщо ми
спробуємо використати його для захисту qubit від помилок це не дуже хороший квантовий код виправлення помилок як ми побачимо він
може виправляти деякі помилки але робить інші помилки більш імовірними однак це перший крок до коду Шора
тому подивімось як він працює для qubit по-перше щоб бути точним коли ми говоримо про трибітовий код повторення що використовується
для qubit ми маємо на увазі кодування qubit як показано на екрані де Alpha 0 плюс beta 1 це
кодується як Alpha 000 плюс beta 111 або іншими словами стандартний базисний стан
повторюється тричі зверни увагу зокрема що це не те саме що триразове повторення квантового стану як у заданому
квантовому стані s кодованому як s тензор s тензор s що є кодуванням яке ми не зможемо
реалізувати для невідомого квантового стану s за теоремою про заборону клонування кодування про яке ми говоримо
з іншого боку дуже легко реалізується ось дуже простий квантовий circuit який виконує це за допомогою двох ініціалізованих робочих qubit і двох
controlled NOT gate тепер припустимо що після виконання кодування сталась помилка
і зокрема припустимо що операція Poly X або іншими словами бітове перекидання відбулось на одному з
qubit і на цьому малюнку це середній qubit звичайно це не єдиний вид помилки який міг статись і ти міг би
заперечити ідею що помилка набирає форму цієї ідеальної унітарної операції але ми повернемося до цього пізніше в уроці і поки що можемо
просто думати про це як про приклад ось результуючий стан він такий самий як оригінальне кодування за винятком
того що середній біт у кожному ket перекинутий очевидно ми можемо побачити це з математичних виразів для стану
але припустимо що у нас є лише три qubit і ми підозрюємо що могло статись бітове перекидання але ми не знаємо який qubit міг бути
уражений одним способом визначити чи сталось бітове перекидання було б виконати стандартне базисне вимірювання і розглянути результат в цьому випадку ми побачимо
або 010 або 110 з імовірностями залежними від Alpha і beta і в будь-якому випадку наш висновок
буде що середній біт перекинувся але на жаль це руйнує оригінальний квантовий стан і цей стан
може бути для нас дорогоцінним адже весь сенс полягає в тому щоб захистити цей квантовий стан тому це не є хорошим
варіантом те що ми натомість можемо зробити — це використати квантовий circuit показаний тут на екрані де ми подаємо закодований стан
на верхні три qubit по суті circuit обчислює парність стандартних
базисних станів для верхніх двох qubit а також для нижніх двох qubit кодування і це виявить
місце бітового перекидання зокрема в цьому випадку ми отримаємо результат один для обох цих перевірок парності і з
цієї інформації ми можемо зробити висновок що саме середній біт відрізняється від двох інших тому він очевидно той що
перекинувся і що важливо це не призводить до колапсу стану тому тепер у нас є шанс спробувати виправити це бітове
перекидання щоб зрештою ми могли мабуть декодувати і отримати назад наш оригінальний стан ми повернемось до виправлення
трохи пізніше але спершу коротко розглянемо інші можливості для помилки бітового перекидання якщо натомість помилка бітового перекидання
сталась на нижньому або лівому qubit то ми отримали б результат один нуль читаючи знизу вгору і знову
стан не змінився б і якщо бітове перекидання сталось на верхньому qubit то результат був би
01 і знову стан не змінюється до речі якщо не було жодного
бітового перекидання то результат вимірювання дорівнює 00 і знову стан виходить незмінним
тож підсумуємо все це у вигляді таблиці де ми перелічуємо кожен з можливих станів які ми отримуємо при щонайбільше одному бітовому перекиданні результати вимірювань
які ми називаємо синдромом у контексті корекції помилок і виправлення яке нам потрібно зробити щоб повернути оригінальне
кодування якщо не було помилки синдром дорівнює 00 і нічого не потрібно робити щоб виправити
стан якщо нижній або крайній лівий qubit зазнав бітового перекидання синдром дорівнює 10 і відповідним виправленням
є застосування X gate до нижнього або крайнього лівого qubit а два інших випадки
аналогічні тому якщо ми застосуємо відповідне виправлення на основі синдрому то ми неодмінно відновимо оригінальне
кодування у всіх чотирьох випадках знову ж ми розглядаємо лише можливість що щонайбільше одне бітове
перекидання сталось це не спрацювало б правильно якби два або три біти перекинулись і ми також не розглядали
можливість інших помилок тепер розглянемо інший тип помилки у квантовому контексті бітові
перекидання не єдині помилки про які нам потрібно турбуватись наприклад нам також потрібно турбуватись про фазові перекидання
або просто фазові фліпи скорочено які описуються Z gate або рівнозначно Poly Z
операціями на жаль трибітовий код повторення повністю не виявляє фазові перекидання наприклад припустимо що ми
кодуємо qubit за допомогою трибітового коду повторення як раніше і фазове перекидання відбувається на середньому
qubit ми отримаємо стан показаний на екрані який є точно таким кодуванням яке ми отримали б якби фазове
перекидання сталось на оригінальному qubit перед кодуванням і тому якщо ми виконаємо той самий
circuit як раніше щоб спробувати виявити помилку ми отримаємо синдром 00 що хибно свідчить про те що жодних помилок не
сталось тому трибітовий код повторення працює для щонайбільше одного бітового перекидання але не виявляє фазові перекидання
насправді це робить речі гіршими в якомусь сенсі тому що тепер у нас в три рази більше qubit які потенційно можуть зазнати фазового перекидання
ми спостерігали що трибітовий код повторення повністю ігнорує фазові перекидання тому він не здається
дуже корисним для роботи з таким видом помилок але насправді ми можемо модифікувати трибітовий код повторення так щоб він
виявляв фазові перекидання і я зараз поясню як це можна зробити ось оригінальний circuit для
кодування qubit за допомогою трибітового коду повторення і спосіб його модифікації дуже простий ми просто застосовуємо
Hadamard gate до кожного qubit кодування Hadamard gate перетворює нульовий стан у стан плюс а одиничний
стан у стан мінус тому загальний ефект полягає в тому що ми отримуємо стан показаний на екрані де ket
плюс-плюс-плюс і ket мінус-мінус-мінус є скороченим позначенням для тензора трьох станів плюс або трьох мінус
станів фазове перекидання або іншими словами Z gate перетворює стани плюс на стани мінус і стани мінус на
стани плюс тому це кодування буде корисним для виявлення та виправлення фазових перекидань і для цього ми можемо
модифікувати circuit виявлення помилок з раніше таким чином ось circuit з раніше і те що ми зробимо це
просто помістимо Hadamard gate як на початку так і в кінці як показано на екрані
ідея дуже проста перші три Hadamard gate перетворюють стани плюс і мінус назад у нульові та одиничні стани ті ж
перевірки парності що й раніше виконуються і потім другий шар Hadamard gate повертає нас назад до нашого
кодування інший спосіб думати про це полягає в тому що ми по суті просто перетворюємо фазові перекидання на бітові перекидання шляхом кон'югування операціями Hadamard
до речі ми можемо трохи спростити circuit цей circuit тут є повністю еквівалентним
і ти можеш перевірити це сам якщо захочеш тому якщо ми подамо наш закодований qubit на цей circuit припускаючи
що фазові перекидання не сталися ми отримаємо синдром 00 що вказує на відсутність фазових перекидань
а якщо у нас є фазове перекидання на верхньому qubit скажімо то крайні праві плюси і мінуси перекидаються
і це призводить до іншого синдрому помилки 01 у цьому випадку що ідентифікує місце фазового перекидання так само
як ми мали для бітового перекидання і ми можемо виправити його застосувавши Z gate до верхнього qubit і ситуація
аналогічна для фазових перекидань на будь-якому з двох інших qubit тому ми справді можемо виявити та
виправити щонайбільше одне фазове перекидання за допомогою цього коду але на жаль як ти міг здогадатись тепер ми більше не можемо
виправляти бітові перекидання однак все не втрачено тому що ми фактично можемо поєднати ці два коди
разом щоб отримати код який може виправляти як бітові перекидання так і фазові перекидання і насправді він зможе
виправити будь-яку помилку на одному qubit настав час обговорити 9-qubit код Шора який є квантовим
кодом виправлення помилок який ми можемо отримати поєднавши два коди які ми щойно бачили тобто трибітовий
код повторення який дозволяє виправити одне бітове перекидання і модифіковану версію цього коду яка дозволяє виправити одне фазове перекидання
якщо бути точніше 9-qubit код Шора — це код який ми отримуємо конкатенуванням двох кодів що означає
що ми спочатку застосовуємо одне кодування яке кодує один qubit у три а потім застосовуємо інше кодування до кожного з
трьох qubit окремо тому ми отримаємо дев'ять qubit загалом ми можемо виразити це у вигляді
схеми circuit наступним чином спочатку застосуємо модифіковану версію трибітового коду повторення
яка виявляє фазові перекидання а потім закодуємо кожен з отриманих qubit незалежно за допомогою оригінального
трибітового коду повторення тому якщо ми трохи зменшимо цей circuit щоб звільнити трохи більше місця ми можемо
описати код дещо в інших термінах описуючи як два стандартних базисних стани для нашого оригінального qubit
кодуються і як тільки ми це знаємо ми можемо визначити за допомогою лінійності як довільний вектор стану qubit
кодується отже це 9-qubit код Шора і ідея полягає в тому що один з кодів дозволяє нам виправляти фазові перекидання
а інший код дозволяє нам виправляти бітові перекидання і як ми побачимо це фактично означатиме що ми можемо
виправити довільну помилку на одному qubit тепер подивімось як ми можемо виявляти та виправляти помилки за допомогою 9-qubit
коду Шора починаючи з бітових перекидань які також називаються X помилками ось circuit який виконує
кодування і просто щоб легше говорити про це ми будемо думати про дев'ять qubit які ми отримуємо з цього коду як розбитих
на три блоки по три qubit де кожен блок представляє кодування яке ми отримуємо застосовуючи
другий крок кодування який є звичайним трибітовим кодом повторення це називається внутрішнім кодом у
цьому контексті тоді як зовнішній код — це код використаний для першого кроку кодування яким у цьому випадку є модифікована
версія трибітового коду повторення що працює для фазових перекидань для виправлення бітових перекидань ми можемо
просто обробляти кожен блок окремо кожен блок є кодуванням qubit за допомогою трибітового коду повторення
і цей код захищає від бітових перекидань припустимо спочатку що X помилка відбувається на будь-якому з qubit
наприклад на середньому qubit в середньому блоці якщо ми незалежно перевіряємо кожен блок на бітові перекидання і
виправляємо будь-які знайдені помилки то ця помилка буде виправлена і оригінальне кодування буде
відновлено насправді у нас навіть може бути кілька X помилок і ми все одно зможемо виправити їх у такий спосіб за умови що помилки знаходяться
в різних блоках якщо б у нас було дві або три X помилки в одному блоці ми були б у скруті але
доки є щонайбільше одна X помилка на блок внутрішній код їх вловить і ми зможемо відновити оригінальний закодований
стан тому виправлення бітових перекидань є досить простою справою для цього коду нам також потрібно розглянути фазові перекидання
або іншими словами Z помилки цього разу не зовсім зрозуміло що нам потрібно робити тому що зовнішній код — це той
що виправляє фазові перекидання але ми не можемо безпосередньо виявляти та виправляти їх тому що внутрішній код якимось чином
заважає але ми незабаром побачимо як це зробити щоб краще зрозуміти як X і Z
помилки працюють і які ефекти вони мають всередині квантових circuit корисно спостерігати кілька простих зв'язків між цими помилками і C
NOT gate і це також буде корисним у пізнішому уроці спочатку почнемо з X помилок
або X gate і того як вони пов'язані з C NOT gate якщо ми застосуємо X gate до
цільового qubit C NOT і потім застосуємо C NOT то це еквівалентно зміні порядку і виконанню C NOT
спочатку з іншого боку якщо ми застосуємо X gate до керуючого qubit C NOT і потім застосуємо C NOT ми не можемо просто
поміняти порядок а натомість нам потрібно застосувати X gate до обох qubit і ти можеш перевірити всі ці зв'язки самостійно
якщо хочеш подумавши про те що відбувається зі стандартними базисними станами наприклад ситуація аналогічна для Z
помилок за винятком того що ролі керуючого та цільового qubit міняються місцями зокрема якщо ми виконаємо
Z gate на керуючому qubit C NOT і потім виконаємо C NOT то це матиме той самий ефект що й виконання
Z gate після C NOT але якщо ми виконаємо Z gate на цільовому qubit натомість то це
еквівалентно спочатку виконанню C NOT і потім застосуванню Z gate до обох qubit і нарешті всі ці
зв'язки є симетричними в тому сенсі що ми завжди можемо поміняти порядок gate з обох боків кожного рівняння
що еквівалентно взяттю оберненого або спряженого транспонованого обох сторін враховуючи що X Z і C NOT
gate є власними оберненими тепер розглянемо фазові перекидання і те як ми можемо виявляти та виправляти
їх за допомогою 9-qubit коду Шора ось наш circuit кодування і ми будемо продовжувати думати про дев'ять
qubit використаних у кодуванні як розбитих на три блоки по три qubit припустимо що Z помилка відбувається на
будь-якому з qubit наприклад на тому що вказано тут використовуючи те що ми щойно спостерігали про Z
gate і C NOT gate це еквівалентно двом Z помилкам перед C NOT одній на
керуючому і одній на цільовому qubit і ці помилки комутують з іншим C NOT у блоці тому ми
можемо поміняти порядок і ось що ми отримуємо нижня Z помилка нічого не робить тому що вона діє на нульовий
стан і ми можемо пересунути все інше і отримати цю схему тому ми виявили що Z помилка десь у
середньому блоці еквівалентна Z помилці на середньому qubit до другої фази кодування і
ти можеш розмірковувати точно так само для Z помилки на будь-якому з qubit фазове перекидання на будь-якому qubit у блоці
еквівалентне фазовому перекиданню на відповідному qubit до внутрішнього кодування і це насправді досить зрозуміло та інтуїтивно якщо ти
думаєш про те як Z помилки впливають на трибітовий код повторення тому один варіант для роботи з Z
помилкою — це декодувати внутрішній код а потім виявити та виправити Z помилки за допомогою зовнішнього коду який є модифікованою
версією трибітового коду повторення яка може виправити Z помилку тому це виправляє нашу Z помилку і
ми могли б перекодувати з внутрішнім кодом якщо захотіли б ми також можемо виправляти Z помилки
на місці так би мовити без декодування та повторного кодування і це досить зрозуміло але щоб пояснити як ми
можемо це зробити нам знадобиться трохи більше місця припустимо що ми декодуємо внутрішній код
а потім обчислюємо синдром для зовнішнього коду тим самим методом що й раніше де ми залучаємо лише три qubit із зовнішнього коду і
потім перекодовуємо ну ми можемо дещо спростити всі ці C NOT і насправді
ми можемо скористатися зв'язками між NOT gate і C NOT gate які ми щойно спостерігали кілька хвилин тому щоб допомогти з цим
завданням і зробивши це ми можемо заощадити чотири C NOT і ось circuit який ми отримуємо якщо Z помилка сталась на одному
з qubit те що синдром говорить нам тепер — це не який qubit зазнав Z помилки а скоріше в якому блоці Z помилка
сталась але це нічого тому що ми знаємо що не важливо який qubit у блоці зазнає Z помилки
ефект однаковий для всіх трьох qubit у цьому блоці і тому ми фактично можемо виправити Z помилку застосувавши Z gate до будь-якого з
qubit у цьому блоці це до речі є прикладом того що називається виродженістю в коді
виправлення помилок де ми не однозначно ідентифікуємо певну помилку але все одно здатні її виправити нарешті припустимо що обидва
бітове перекидання і фазове перекидання відбуваються можливо на одному qubit наприклад припустимо що
бітове і фазове перекидання відбуваються на цьому qubit ось тут виявляється що ці помилки можуть бути
виявлені та виправлені повністю незалежно і насправді не важливо чи ми виправляємо кожен блок для
бітового перекидання спочатку а потім виправляємо фазові перекидання або якщо ми робимо це в зворотному порядку щоб побачити це спочатку зауважимо
що порядок цих помилок не важливий тому ми можемо поміняти їх місцями якщо хочемо причина цього не в тому що
X і Z комутують тому що вони не комутують X * Z дорівнює від'ємному Z * X але
від'ємний множник 1 не має жодного ефекту в цій ситуації тому що це глобальна фаза тепер ми можемо перемістити Z помилку так само як
раніше і на цьому етапі очевидно що якби ми спочатку виправили кожен блок для X помилок а потім виправили
для Z помилок то ми виправили б обидві помилки альтернативно якщо з якоїсь причини
ми вирішили б спочатку виправити Z помилки ми могли б це зробити і X помилка абсолютно не має жодного ефекту в цьому процесі
це має бути правдою тому що по-перше X помилка комутує з кожним окремим gate в circuit що обчислює
синдром для зовнішнього коду і по-друге порядок між X помилкою і Z gate який ми застосовуємо для виправлення
не важливий так само як ми аргументували коли Z gate була помилкою тому це дозволяє виправлення Z
помилки і ми можемо потім виправити кожен блок щоб усунути X помилку тому ми стверджуємо що ми
можемо виправити X помилку Z помилку або обидві на будь-якому одному з qubit використовуючи цей код
насправді ми можемо виправити більше помилок ніж це наприклад кілька X помилок доки вони потрапляють до різних блоків
або кілька Z помилок доки щонайбільше один блок отримує непарну кількість але в подальшому найбільш актуальним буде
те що ми можемо виправити X помилку Z помилку або обидві на будь-якому одному qubit і в останній частині уроку
ми побачимо як цього насправді достатньо щоб зробити висновок що цей код може виправляти довільну помилку на будь-якому одному
qubit перш ніж ми перейдемо до останньої частини уроку в якій ми розглянемо довільні квантові помилки ми коротко
розглянемо продуктивність N-qubit коду Шора коли помилки представлені матрицями Паулі відбуваються випадково на
qubit щоб бути більш конкретним розглянемо просту модель шуму де помилки відбуваються незалежно на qubit
причому кожен qubit зазнає помилки з імовірністю P і без кореляції між помилками на різних
qubit найгірший сценарій для 9-qubit коду Шора полягає в тому що Y помилка або іншими словами і X помилка і Z
помилка відбуваються на кожному ураженому qubit і ми будемо припускати цей найгірший сценарій просто щоб отримати межу
на продуктивність коду але ти також можеш розглянути наприклад що три помилки Паулі є однаково
ймовірними тепер припустимо що Q є qubit у деякому конкретному стані який ми хочемо захистити від помилок і уявімо що
у нас є можливість використати 9-qubit код Шора чи варто його використовувати ну відповідь не обов'язково
так тому що якщо занадто багато шуму або іншими словами P занадто велике використання коду Шора могло б насправді зробити речі
гіршими так само як ми мали для коду повторення коли P більше за 1/2 але якщо P достатньо мале то
відповідь — так нам варто використовувати код тому подивімось чому це так і що означає P бути занадто великим або достатньо малим
для цього коду код Шора може виправити будь-яку помилку Паулі на одному qubit і в найгіршому
випадку коли помилки Паулі є Y помилками це означає що код успішно захищає Q з імовірністю яку задає
вираз показаний на екрані зокрема код працює коли немає помилок і це відбувається
з імовірністю 1 мінус P у дев'ятому степені тому що є дев'ять qubit які кожен повинен бути незачеплений і він працює коли є
рівно одна помилка і враховуючи що є дев'ять різних qubit які потенційно можуть бути уражені це відбувається з імовірністю 9 * P * 1 мінус P у восьмому степені
з іншого боку якщо ми не використовуємо код наш єдиний qubit не буде уражений помилкою з
імовірністю 1 мінус P тому код допомагає лише тоді коли перша імовірність більша за другу
оскільки ці вирази представляють наші імовірності успіху в двох випадках коли ми використовуємо код і коли ми
не використовуємо ось графік цих двох функцій для малих значень P і ми знаходимо що точка беззбитковості знаходиться приблизно при
3 і 3/4 відсотках тому якщо P менше за це значення то код
допомагає в точці беззбитковості імовірності рівні тому ми просто витрачаємо свій час разом з 8 qubit якщо
використовуємо код але в іншому випадку це не шкодить і після цієї точки ми абсолютно не повинні використовувати цей код
тому що він насправді збільшує шанс помилки на закодованому qubit який ми зазвичай називаємо
логічним qubit у цьому контексті і це відбувається просто тому що шанс двох або більше помилок на дев'яти qubit є
більшим ніж шанс однієї помилки на одному qubit для значень P в цьому діапазоні 3 і 3/4 відсотки можуть не видатись дуже
хорошим показником особливо порівняно з 50% що є аналогічною точкою беззбитковості для трибітового коду повторення для
класичної інформації але захищати квантову інформацію складніше і крім того хоча цей
код є блискучим відкриттям як самий перший квантовий код виправлення помилок і він чудово підходить для педагогічних цілей справа в тому що
це просто не дуже хороший код з практичної точки зору до цього моменту ми розглядали X помилки
і Z помилки в контексті 9-qubit коду Шора тепер розглянемо довільні помилки
починаючи спочатку з унітарних помилок наприклад така помилка може відповідати дуже малому
повороту блох-сфери можливо представляючи помилку спричинену gate який не є ідеальним наприклад
або це може бути будь-яка інша унітарна операція на qubit і не обов'язково щось близьке до тотожної
операції може здатись що виправлення таких помилок важко адже існує нескінченно багато можливих помилок такого
роду і неможливо уявити що ми могли б якось точно ідентифікувати яка помилка і скасувати її але нам
насправді не потрібно робити нічого іншого ніж те що ми вже обговорили доки ми можемо виправити бітове перекидання фазове перекидання або обидва ми
фактично досягнемо успіху у виправленні довільної унітарної помилки на одному qubit і я зараз поясню чому це
так по-перше як і всі матриці 2x2 ми можемо виразити довільну унітарну матрицю
що представляє помилку на одному qubit як лінійну комбінацію чотирьох матриць Паулі включаючи тотожну
матрицю і до речі як ти міг помітити я використовую великі X Y та Z для позначення нетотожних матриць Паулі
і я продовжуватиму це для решти серії це є загальноприйнятим у квантовій корекції помилок і це також робить
речі трохи легшими для читання в цьому контексті також буде зручно використовувати нижні індекси для вказання якому
qubit застосовується дана унітарна операція на qubit наприклад якщо ми використовуємо
нумерацію qubit від Qiskit починаючи з qubit нуль справа то ми маємо вирази показані на екрані для
різних унітарних операцій на одиничних qubit де в кожному випадку ми тензоруємо унітарну матрицю з тотожною матрицею
на кожному іншому qubit тому зокрема ми можемо виразити UK тобто U застосовану до qubit K як ту ж саму
лінійну комбінацію що й раніше за винятком того що кожна матриця Паулі застосовується до qubit K нам не потрібно турбуватись з
нижнім індексом для тотожності до речі тут розуміється що це тотожність на всіх
qubit тепер припустимо що sigma є 9-qubit кодуванням стану qubit якщо помилка U відбувається на
qubit K то ми отримуємо UK * sigma що ми можемо виразити як лінійну комбінацію операцій Паулі що діють на sigma що
звичайно є просто sigma у випадку тотожності на цьому етапі буде корисно спостерігати що матриця Паулі Y
дорівнює i * X * Z тому ми можемо зробити цю заміну в нашому
виразі отже ця помилка сталась і тепер припустимо що ми намагаємось виправити її використовуючи ту саму процедуру що й
раніше першим кроком є обчислення синдрому який у випадку коду Шора є 8 бітами довжиною два біти для кожного з
трьох разів коли ми використовуємо внутрішній код разом з додатковими двома бітами для зовнішнього коду але це насправді не важливо ми можемо просто думати про це як
деякий рядок фіксованої довжини ось опис стану який ми отримуємо безпосередньо перед вимірюванням синдрому де кожен
синдром є тими 8 бітами які ми отримуємо від відповідної помилки Паулі зверни увагу на цьому етапі що дві
системи в загальному є скорельованими і це справді є ключем до того щоб все це спрацювало вимірюючи синдром те що
ми ефективно робимо — це колапсуємо стан до такого де одна з чотирьох операцій Паулі була застосована до
K-го qubit sigma і ми дізнаємось з синдрому яка операція Паулі це була тому ми можемо виправити це якщо
потрібно зокрема якщо ми вимірюємо синдром і робимо відповідне виправлення то ми отримуємо стан
показаний на екрані який важливо є добутковим станом у нас є наше оригінальне незіпсоване кодування як
правий тензорний множник що є найважливішим тут і зліва у нас є матриця густини s яка
описує випадковий синдром помилки але вже немає жодної кореляції з системою про яку ми дбаємо яка
знаходиться справа тому що помилки виправлені в цей момент ми можемо викинути qubit синдрому або скинути їх
якщо хочемо використати їх знову і це насправді досить важливо тому що ось як випадковість або ентропія
породжена помилками видаляється з системи і ось як працює дискретизація помилок принаймні для унітарних
помилок по суті вимірюючи синдром ми ефективно проектуємо помилку на помилку яку описує
матриця Паулі на перший погляд може здатись надто добрим щоб бути правдою що ми можемо виправляти довільні унітарні помилки
ось так навіть помилки які є мізерними і ледве помітними самі по собі але важливо усвідомити тут
що це унітарна помилка на одному qubit і за задумом коду операція на одному qubit не може змінити
стан логічного qubit який кодується все що вона може зробити — це перемістити стан за межі простору дійсних
кодувань але тоді виправлення повертають його назад туди де він був нарешті розглянемо що відбувається
коли відбувається довільна не обов'язково унітарна помилка налаштування таке саме як раніше
ми закодували один qubit у 9 за допомогою коду Шора і деяка довільна помилка представлена каналом qubit theta
відбувається на одному з qubit як ми побачимо все складеться приблизно так само
як і для унітарних помилок і перший крок до підтвердження цього полягає в тому щоб розглянути крауси-розклад нашої
помилки те що ми можемо зробити тепер — це слідувати точно тій самій логіці що й для унітарних помилок за винятком того що ми застосовуємо цю
логіку до крауси-матриць а не до однієї унітарної матриці що представляє помилку
зокрема кожна крауси-матриця може бути виражена як лінійна комбінація матриць Паулі і це дозволяє нам
виразити дію цієї помилки phi на будь-який qubit K на якому вона відбувається у формі показаній тут на
екрані все що ми реально робимо тут — це розкладаємо крауси-матриці як лінійні комбінації матриць Паулі
якщо ми потім обчислимо та виміряємо синдром помилки і виправимо будь-які виявлені помилки ми отримаємо
подібний стан до того що ми мали у випадку унітарної помилки я не буду детально розписувати це все досить схоже на унітарний
випадок і також трохи заплутаніше записати але концептуально це досить
зрозуміло варто зазначити що все це узагальнюється на інші квантові коди виправлення помилок включаючи коди які можуть виправляти помилки на кількох
qubit у такому випадку помилки на кількох qubit можуть бути виражені як лінійні комбінації тензорних добутків матриць Паулі
і відповідно різні можливі синдроми описуватимуть виправлення які виконуються на кількох qubit а не лише на одному
qubit але основна ідея є абсолютно такою самою знову вимірюючи синдром
ми ефективно проектуємо або колапсуємо помилки на дискретний набір можливостей представлених тензорними
добутками матриць Паулі і виправляючи ці помилки тобто помилки Паулі ми можемо відновити оригінальний
закодований стан тим часом будь-яка випадковість породжена в процесі переміщується у qubit синдрому які ми потім можемо
відкинути або скинути що є вирішальним тому що ось як ентропія породжена помилками та вимірюваннями синдрому
видаляється з системи і це кінець уроку в якому ми вперше розглянули
квантову корекцію помилок включаючи 9-qubit код Шора і дискретизацію помилок сподіваюсь ти приєднаєшся до мене на
наступному уроці в якому ми обговоримо стабілізаторний формалізм який забезпечує нас потужним інструментом для опису та
аналізу великого та цікавого класу квантових кодів виправлення помилок включаючи ті що є перспективними кандидатами для
справжніх квантових комп'ютерів до зустрічі